[Musique]
nous nous étions quatre et ça s'est pas
très bien passé ce ballon a buté une
fois deux fois
il ya une déchirure dans le vallon le
gaz s'est échappé sur étincelles s'est
enflammé michel d'activité n'a pas lâché
sa caméra
on a vu arriver les gendarmes pour nous
emmener en prison parce que qu'est-ce
que c'est que c'est rigolo télévision je
te soutiens brille enfin le journal tv
alors inexistant ça n'existait
absolument pas
[Musique]
hélas même madame monsieur bonsoir
bonsoir mesdames bon sens mesdemoiselles
bonsoir messieurs
[Musique]
avoue jacques salbert à voulons
avoue moscou
[Musique]
méditer sans taper santé yeh
ce prix voilà maintenant la chasse à
l'automobiliste paul huber
[Musique]
e